oh man
mah goodness add your Jasper's after
house of him oh man Oh what's going on
guys how's everybody doing today hope
you guys are doing good
I need to get my beard trimmed up my
moustache hair is starting to go crazy
question when will I do The Walking Dead
comics I get that question so often okay
here's the thing about the Walking Dead
The Walking Dead is kind of a weird
situation when it comes to comic books
because sometimes they'll do well
depending on what I call it other times
they won't like I made a couple of
Walking Dead videos like here's what
happens to me get here's what happens to
Jesus but those were really popular
those he's broke a million views I think
because it was at the time when like
negan and Jesus at first popped up and
it was like here's what happens to him
you know so people were really excited
to see what happens to those characters
within the context of the show the
problem is the Walking Dead is not
popular outside of the show so if I put
a video it's not going to perform well
and at the end of the day I do not want
to upload a video that doesn't perform
well it's just a moral thing like it
just makes you take a moral hit and it
cuz ex do I have a watch good series no
I've only done before Watchmen um D
media Matt Jim Jasper's vs. Emperor
Joker uh Emperor Joker hands down the
power is just too extreme who's the best
Green Lantern and why is a guy garden uh
got gardeners awesome this what what a
question that's an amazing question um
but now it's just kind of a mixed bag
with those with those things always the
question I was going to ask answer
before I don't know what question I was
going to answer before I kind of forgot
what I was going to answer but uh then
and scrolling back through to see what
it was
I've not had a chance to read today's
comics by the way so well I can't find
it crud sorry guys I don't mean to be
that one guy but I can't I can't find
that question that people were asking um
anyway uh let's see
what's the news Hulk storyline going to
be after world will bring your whole no
idea but okay so that brings us to the
x-men all right perhaps one of the most
common questions that I get consistently
is what do I read with the x-men after
house of it it's the one thing that
confuses so many people you know I don't
know where to start with the x-men I
want to read the x-men like what I you
know where do I start with the x-men at
the House of M all right I've been going
through making a spreadsheet on the
chronological reading order of the x-men
alright it goes into the it's the house
of an aftermath which really runs up to
like x-men deadly Genesis then it goes
into the Dark Age of the x-men which is
like endangered species and Messiah
Complex and divided we standard manifest
destiny really should survive atleast
and the Utopia age when the x-men moved
to utopia the island off the coast of
San Francisco that starts with manifest
destiny and then it goes into dark rain
and then it goes into the heroic age and
then it goes into the post schism age
alright we're 226 videos 226 videos
today if we work if we were going to do
that
226 videos uh oh man is absolutely crazy
I've never tried doing a video on the
question from from DC Comics
I mean it's absolutely nuts but the
reason why it's so big is because this
covers the entirety of the x-men
universe with the exception of like
Excalibur and exile I'm never going to
cover scaliger excels like I'm never
going to cover either one of those but
you know the other stuff you know kind
of the x-men x-men universe centric
stuff is kind of it who are the most
significant characters from x-men who
lost their powers Wow a lot of them have
lost their powers um probably the most
significant would be Wolverine who lost
his healing factor and it results in him
dying that's probably the most
significant character that I can think
of so who would win Superman one officer
in 1 million or Superboy Ron uh Superman
1 million Franklin Richards vs. the void
my voice is super hot I appreciate that
definitely Franklin Richards I'm sorry
the void just because the void is more
experienced that how to use his powers
than Franklin Richards is so but yeah so
no way he would be why would you ask me
my opinion if you're gonna tell me my
opinions wrong I don't understand that
hey Rob uh which character do you like
better Batman or Superman well I like
Superman more you're wrong
alright like oh man but uh no it's it's
just it's weird to me Batman versus okay
weird love versus guys that's one of the
reasons why I stopped comics and coffee
is because all people did would just ask
versus videos like versus topics like
you know this character dresses this
character that character versus that
character I want to answer like some
actual questions questions so um let's
see do you think there would ever be a
jla/avengers team up again probably not
I think Marvel and DC are just kind of
too stubborn to to decide to do either
one to be honest to team up I mean it's
at this point they don't mean
just never going to happen Marvel
strongly enough as it is I mean truth be
told
being able to organize like a team-up
would be beyond their means at the
moment so explain the sky fathers um sky
fathers are simple enough I mean they're
not hard at all I do not know what they
are like you don't understand the
premise of the sky fathers because I can
explain that but I mean no in terms of
like an on the spot like a character
explanation on the sky father said I
can't do that right now I have to do my
research so a story from DC rebirth
that's not amazing everything from DC
rebirth is amazing Wow Roderick Rogers
holy cow cut you live finally cut you
alive can you explain why Batman and
Catwoman are in love with each other or
why DC wants to push bad cat instead of
the Bruce Tyler relationships because it
just makes good sense
honestly winter hit back at it again Rob
thank you winter
it just makes good sense for me for a
Batman and Catwoman I mean I don't know
why it would be anything else to be
honest I mean it just you know she's
they've crossed paths so many times and
they've been you know in relationships
and been enemies so many times Batman
and Catwoman makes more sense to me than
Batman and Talia al Ghul so plus there's
the whole story about Damian Wayne
trying to like walk away from his past
with regard to the League of Assassins
and it wouldn't make a whole lot of
sense if he was trying to walk away from
his past while at the same time his mom
was getting with that in so it'd be kind
of an issue but yeah the robbed poor is
already done the Lantern Corps rings I'm
going to select the winners probably
here in the next few weeks I want to get
people ample time because it coming with
it the way I have like when I uploaded
that video it was people who were
getting out and going into summer and so
I want to make sure they had a chance to
you know throw their name in the Hat and
that kind of a thing plus I'm in the
process of moving so give myself a
little bit of time but how many times
have I seen Wonder Woman I've seen it
once I've only ever seen it once so um
am i doing Teen Titans rebirth yes
Damian knows best comes out when is
Damian knows best because Lazarus
contract comes out this weekend so
Damian knows best comes out tomorrow and
then Titans rebirth Maid in Manhattan
comes out the same day we're going to do
two videos and then a Thanos returns
Thanos from Marvel now comes out and
then there's X amount of war from
valiant and then Teen Titans rise of
Aqualad and then Lazarus contract I'm
debating on doing rise of Aqualad I
don't care enough about him it's like it
but it's like a two issue story so it's
not that worked so let's see uh who's my
least favorite comic book character
Darwin is an omega-level mutant he's
really strong my least favorite kind of
a character yeah he's a yeah he just
manipulates water he does what Mara does
my least favorite kind of a character
alone it used to be spider-man but I
enjoy spider-man now I don't know I'm
not really sure to be honest
hmm
I'm probably Captain Britain I don't
want to care about a middle so I don't
know um let's see yours is the wasp
minds of the son opinions on x-men blue
and gold I mean it's kind of a cool idea
it's definitely a return to familiarity
I think x-men blue is more interesting
than x-men gold in terms of like just
the story overall in like the characters
and so on and so forth but it was always
like that like even the original x-men
blue and x-men gold like I want to say
was the original x-men blue that was
that people enjoyed more than the x-men
gold so you know it's like a monster
truck you can pour under your face yeah
Bronto that's what plants like hey Rob
are you planning on doing JSA soon I've
been debating that by the way thanks for
the for the two bucks I've just I've
been debating that um when Justice
League comes out there's the new 52
Justice League that I want to cover but
I've also thought about JSA and the the
problem with JSA is there wouldn't
really be a reason to do it as cool as
it is and as interesting as it is really
until Superman versus you know what's
his name comes out until Superman versus
uh dr. Manhattan comes out we won't know
if the JSA are going to play any measure
of role I mean we saw Jay Garrick in the
button but he was there and now he's
gone so we have no idea if he's ever
going to come back I mean there was
Johnny Thunder we've seen him but we
haven't really seen anybody else as far
as the original JSA goes at least as you
guys think about it but if they do end
up coming back then I'll probably end up
doing the or doing a Jeff Jones JSA kind
of like a lead up or something like that
so favorite candy comic uh probably EXO
Man O'War to be honest either that or
like east of West right now those are
two of my favorite comics so at least in
terms of Indies anyway
Jasna stands for Justice Society of
America yes it does
let's see I'm the best thing coming out
of DC rebirth I appreciate that as the
right now still alive I have no idea and
I have no
an ask infamous Iron Man is amazing yeah
I really love Ruby Williams Iron Man I
think she's a great Iron Man um let's
see what's the best cosplay I've ever
seen and done I've never done cosplay I
don't do cosplay but one of the best
cosplays I've ever seen was probably the
guy who was dressed up as I think was a
guy dressed up as Anna it was this great
big huge like Thanos saying it was
pretty stellar like it was pretty insane
um I'd like to at some point you know
just for the sake of having it out there
so when it's Green Lantern coming back I
have Green Lantern coming back windows
Green Lantern coming back because we
have to do ion see I think it comes back
mid-june yeah nothing comes back made
you that's one of those series of like
we do because it's so long like we do it
when we have time to do it to be honest
just because it's so lengthy I mean it'd
be different if it was like a quick you
know several issue run but it's such a
long run that it would take forever for
us to finish off I mean I'm just kind of
interesting I don't know if you don't
give me a rock or ring you'll make your
own phantom rock or rain no um see okay
see here's the deal I mean we might drop
rise of Aqualad to be honest and just
see Lazarus contract because I already
have like I on like that one's already
finished and uploaded at least I think
it's finished and uploaded
I know it's finished it might be
uploaded I'm not a hundred sure let us
go to our secret videos that you guys
are never able to find and locate it
Adam warlock is not dead Adam warlock
was The Living Tribunal until he was
killed by master order and Lord cast um
seriously no joke he was The Living
Tribunal and then they killed him
the power of ion
ion ion that has not been uploaded yet
okay oh that was already done so that
one just needs to go up but uh yeah it's
already recorded so we will go ahead and
do that well throw in because I really
want to get back into it because the
longer I wait the more likely people are
to forget about it so we'll do that
because we have Lazarus contract and
then we'll then we get back to the
chance of just being able to do our
classic DC every severy saturday so um
let's see we're mnestheus
yeah do you plan on covering any DC
vertigo not really never really plan on
doing any vertigo stuff but um well Sony
kill Deadpool Sony doesn't have to Fox
that's Deadpool I don't know why that
Killam it's it's really the only comic
book based character they have it's
making that's successful so it's the
only good movie they made and they're
going to screw it up at some point so
Wow Robert Rogers well we go
since Marvel is going to do another hard
soft reboot is it worth reading any of
the solo series ie spider-man and this
will iron and black panther last one of
the reasons why I dropped off is because
it's the same thing with like like you
know with with Secret Wars alright so
Marvel had all their own solo series
going you can actually look at the sales
you're going to look at the month to
month sales and see what they started
dropping off but Marvel announced Secret
Wars and they were like all Secret Wars
is coming it's all-new all-different
marvel everything you know is going to
change it's gonna be totally different
format is now and then people were like
well there's no reason for me to read
these books anymore and so they
literally just stopped reading them they
just started dropping off in sales
the only exception that was when we got
to like the last days of characters at
the last days of asgaard and so on and
so forth and so what ended up happening
is with this like if we know that secret
Empire is going to lead into you know
watching makalah like we don't it's
going to lead into hey Rob just wanted
to show support keep it up I appreciate
it Chris Chris Babb um if we know what's
going to lead into like you know more
legacy immoral legacy is going to change
everything then what's the point of
reading any of that stuff right now
we're going over any of those things
right now you know what little they have
to
to Marvel legacy starts and what
understand what's going on now as far as
I'm aware from what from what I've been
able to tell from what I've read
nothing's going to change everything is
going to be the exact same as it is now
except maybe the shift and the focus of
the stories might change a little bit
but like the rosters are going to change
or stay the same the characters are
going to stay the same high side thank
you I think that's how you pronounce
your last name Syd maybe um everything
is going to stay the same except for
like you know older characters are going
to come back so like you know the
original Wolverine I guess is going to
come back you know I don't I don't know
will you ever do a video on rwy what's
that I have no idea what our wiv is
unless you're talking about Ruby which
that would be part of the whole x-men
one that we would do but no I don't know
I mean what i wouldn't say it's
pointless is it's like that is the story
that's setting the stage for everything
i mean to say secret secret empire is
pointless would be like saying Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers pointless now
it sets the stage for everything that
happens so it's it'll probably have a
pretty significant ending like if
there's any one title that kind of has
to be read it's probably that one to be
honest so let's see a hypervenom verse
yeah I'm really excited for venom verse
I'm pretty ecstatic
static shock versus a lecture of
probably static shock because static
shock can do a lot more with their
powers anything else so let's see
opinions on the injustice timeline I dig
it other thing injustice timeline is
pretty stellar so how do I feel about
secret Empire
I love secret Empire I know a lot of
people don't really like it but I love
it like I think it's an amazing story
especially the ending number three the
way number three ended was mind blowing
I mean it's constant cliffhangers but I
love the way the story's being done so I
mean it's it's kind of a weird scenario
but I'm the one who got you into comics
what are your thoughts on grab bags hit
or miss I got 50 random college for 25
bucks
they're really getting missed I mean you
see Brad baggage at conventions all the
time you know you see grab bags
everywhere you know it's just it really
is hit and miss like doing it's it's hit
and miss in so far as like you're not
going to get it like you're probably get
a grab bag
and end up seeing like New Mutants
number 98 I mean it's like when you go
to conventions like the convention like
the shopkeepers like they comb over
their comics several times to make sure
they haven't thrown like a super rare
comic in the bargain bin I mean that's
one of the downsides of come up with
conventions is that if you're not buying
anything they get really boring really
fast you go there you walk before 1:00
so then you're done you're like okay and
we're done here now so are you planning
on doing any more wonder woman since
ticket a and Justice Li were just like
one more popular oh well I tried it with
Superman and Wonder Woman and people I
mean it wasn't nearly as popular it
didn't meet my standard on whether or
not I continued a series and so because
of that I was like well you know it's a
fun little story that we did but you
know we probably will do anything with
it
I think Wonder Woman is a contextual
thing it really depends um you um still
like people still view me as like the
marble guy which I guess is kind of good
or bad but yeah I don't know trying to
make a name as a DC guy sort of tough
but when you're doing when he did Marvel
for so long so um let's see Ninja
Turtles versus Power Rangers at the
Power Rangers why is that even a
question the best Hydra cap moment
probably when he picked up Thor's hammer
from the Free Comic Book Day issue so um
so Adam warlock is not dead but was
killed by master burn in order and Lord
chaos so it doesn't that make him dead
yeah I guess he is dead now I mean he
was killed by master order and Lord
chaos so Franklin Richards was with the
Phoenix force versus the first firmament
plans on doing fatal attractions do not
plan on doing fatal attractions and we
have no idea what full like with the
full power of the first firm it is so I
can't begin on it to offer that but if I
had to go with that I'd say like adult
Franklin Richards with the Phoenix force
you probably went so is there any more
incredible content coming soon yes well
that's one of the things that I'm trying
to figure out is it may be one of those
things where it's easier to do because
the Incredible Hulk isn't like in order
to get caught up with the Incredible
Hulk we have like a handful maybe like
10 or 11 videos until we're done because
there is
let's see where's my Incredible Hulk
playlist or order there is the
Incredible Hulk volumes 1 through 4
which is 1 through 15
there's indestructible Hulk volumes 1
through 4 there's the original sin which
is where he fights Iron Man we learn the
actual like the true origin of the
Incredible Hulk
and then there's Hulk which I believe
that one is the doc Samson 1 i Kevin
roughed up my head
then there's savage hope volumes 1 & 2 I
think that's it and then it goes into
all-new all-different marvel and all-new
all-different you know Amadeus Cho Hulk
so we may end up doing those through
Yanis but what we might do with those is
we might do those closer to Ragnarok
since Thor since Hulk's going to be in
that movie we might end up doing those
closer just because you know we're
really popular then so no idea what
happened to juggernaut so you do I think
Bruce manatee Incredible Hulk is coming
back yeah he's coming back with Marvel
legacy I'm pretty sure so I mean
honestly super name power will probably
in with somebody grabbing the Cosmic
Cube and just being like we need all the
good guys to come back like the only way
to fix this is to have the good guy the
original good guys back and then
something along those lines so they
don't get will result in all those
classic characters returning so um let's
see
chillin in the chat when Marvel hero fit
best in the DC of what Mahiro would fit
best in the DC Universe um we probably
spotted man to be honest had to pick one
or Captain America so who's my favorite
reverse-flash you Bart fallen definitely
I think he's the best one please do more
please don't do any more alien about
Victor stone cyborg well now I've got to
do more alien I mean when you don't ask
like when you tell me not to do it I got
to do more on and I'm never gonna do
side work I'm sorry that's never going
to happen
I just I'm not I can't I tried I
literally tried to read the first volume
of cyborg like imitation of life and I
was like that's not going to happen why
I'm not going to I can't do this but it
just doesn't interest me it just it's a
story that just does not resonate with
me in any way you know it's just it's
not it's not that I think it's a
terrible thing it's just to me it's not
I just don't really dig it so I love
your videos man any spider-man videos
coming out just finish appear spider-man
and enjoy the heck out of it what does
the story go after that's what I'm
trying to figure out that really is the
most of the more immediate question
really more so than the x-men there's
two ways that we could go with this we
could do spider-verse and we can do like
spider versus pretty straightforward we
can just do coming home we can do the
other acts one two three and four and
then go into original sin which is the
origin of semi moon and then just go
into edge of spider-verse volumes one
two and three the only problem with this
so I have this great big huge
conversation with Sal overcoming pop we
were talking about what's-his-name about
Cain Cain is like a ridiculous character
it's ridiculous situation Wow
Metal Gear Kirin holy cow hi from Sydney
Australia been a Marvel guy for a while
but you converted me ended up buying all
of Jeff Jones Green Lantern are you
going to cover he adjusted to comics
keep up the seller videos I'll cover
justice - somewhere along the line but I
had to move mine because Ben he had his
and he couldn't he couldn't reschedule
because even have any videos to back it
up in case he had to move it so um
anyway um I mean I can just say it's
came in so far that Kane was a clone at
one point and then he's not a clone of
like it's it's kind of a weird situation
when I can literally just kind of write
him off in a five minute explanation and
call it a day but after a light in terms
of like the chronology that's thus the
spider-verse
direction we could go or we could skip
fighter the spider-verse in its entirety
and we could just say hey it's it's
basically the Parker look which is
immediately what happens after superior
spider-man followed by a graveyard shift
and then it goes into only water from
amazing spider-man and the reason why we
can get away with that is because of the
fact that Ben Riley does come back in
clone conspiracy but it's the main
Marvel Universe Ben Riley not the
alternate reality Ben Riley that we saw
in spider-verse so we could really just
kind of skip over spider-verse and it
has no goings on no bearings with what
happens right now the only exception of
that might be squad spider-gwen and we
can literally just say it's an alternate
reality version of Gwen Stacy was bitten
by a radioactive spider
instead of Peter Parker they met during
spider-verse and she just stuck around
ever since it's like we can we can
really just like hand that in
in a two minute explanation and be fine
so besides she's popular enough right
now that not very many people need to
have her existence explained to her so
um yeah not alone I mean honestly we
might skip spider-verse to be quite
frank I mean and just go with superior
spider-man remember go with the fallout
to superior spider-man the question is
when would we do that look at our videos
because we're here when would we do that
yeah I mean we would do it the week the
movie comes out but see that's doubling
up we could also just not double up we
could start like next week or the week
after and just sort of go at that and
see what happens yeah I mean
here's astonishing x-men volumes 1 & 2
we could do as suddenly x-men volumes
wanted to see how we will respond to
that and then make that decision based
on whether or not we do more x-men stuff
so Luke 8 stories absolutely not I tried
that I tried that with Luke Cage like
Power Man and Iron Fist and people did
not care no one cared and that's that's
the thing as a youtuber you kind of have
like you have to upload content that's
going to get views otherwise what's the
point of having a youtube channel but
there are stories that I know that
people won't care that they don't care
about that they won't watch but I read
them anyway like Captain America Sam
Wilson or like Power Man and Iron Fist
or something along those lines so let's
see uh how to kill squirrel uh I'd like
to at some point no idea but we are oh I
just send this to Star Wars explain I
hit some this over to him let's see get
lower then
she's really hot she's all tatted up
though I can't say the tattoos do a
whole lot for me but she's pretty
good-looking alright um let's see at
sores explain hey man I have that Darth
Vader Red Lantern script
we're hit me up on skype
all right and then we will tweet that to
him all right
anyway um yeah I've been I've been
toying around with the idea of
audiobooks just kind of like messing
around with it was a little bit and
seeing more than I would work but can
you cover also our Superman I've thought
about that I've been trying to find a
place to fit in it that's a problem and
like there's there's so many topics that
I want to cover and not enough days like
not enough days to cover them honestly I
feel like like Geoff Johns Green Lantern
man like as much as I love it as much as
I want to keep doing it it feels like I
have to kind of shove everything else
out of the way to make room like like
any other possible stories that I could
do I have to put on a hole because
because that's so huge you know it's
it's kind of crazy I think I want my
story time the max it's I would love to
the problem is the matches really adult
oriented that's the same reason I can't
do Punisher max I want to do Punisher
max but I can't do Punisher max because
of YouTube's hold family-friendly you
know we still believe it's you know
1980s instead of 2017 we're still living
in the past YouTube's whole policy was
not really living in the modern day so
anyway I love Marvel now yeah it was
kind of it was pretty fun can I do cable
cables part of that whole x-men run that
were that we're talking about doing I
frequently use your channel has a
reference point when talking talking
comics and I make sure people know
you're the place to go thanks so much
well thank you angel gamer in Angeles
Angeles
I guess not really sure that's how you
pronounce it uh-oh mopey yeah how's the
Hazzard chronology going I know it's
kind of messy well right now right now
on whatchamacallit oh cool
there was Alex right there hey man hey
Star Wars explained on skype that I
talked here because I'm cool and he's
cool and we're cool people
all right um what are we talking about I
don't know oh yeah it's not what were
what were we talking about before what
were we saying how do you not remember I
do not remember yeah um let's see
chronology oh yeah the x-men chronology
yeah so if we were to start right now
all right with the at rhinology we're
only up to the heroic age those you guys
who don't know back in 2010 2011 coming
after coming out of Dark Reign Marvel
launched something called the heroic age
which was basically just like a
rebranding like Marvel now we're only
well different Marvel or Marvel now 1.0
2.0 so on and so forth it was a
rebranding that was designed to say hey
guys we're getting into cheerful you
know more cheerful stories instead of
like you know stories where we basically
come off as miserable human beings and
so because of that it led into a whole
bunch of different things anyway um
getting all the way up until schism and
x-men legacy which is when everybody
ends up going back that's 226 video 0
would that it would take just to get up
to schism just to get to that story
granted that's pretty close to the
launch of Marvel now and whole new all
new x-men but still that's it's 226
videos it is insane how many videos that
would be I mean it'd be multiple
playlists like I couldn't do all in one
playlist by to 226 so it's insane so if
yes madness is exactly what it is but
you also got a thing too if we did this
x-men chronology it would be everything
about the x-men like everything you know
every single thing there is about the
x-men I mean what like like fear itself
would get covered Regenesis schism
second coming to protonation acts all
that stuff everything from House of em
all the way up to schism Cable would be
in there cable and hope all that kind of
stuff so there are some videos that I've
already done like
logan and like a secret invasion and
what we're Hulk stuff like that but you
know it's it's insane
so but I don't know the dark side war
continuation well that's what I'm think
about doing it's going back and just
remastering all the videos on new video
to Justice League and running all the
way up to Darkseid more with the start
with really leading into the Justice
League release of the movie so I don't
know let's see you have read all you
have superpowers I have superpowers I
guess the best Hulk story I think is
what we're Hawking it's amazing
can I do juggernaut with a Speed Force
yeah I'll probably end up doing that one
that one just seems like it's too fun to
pass up so who are the Rob with winter
the Rob for sure it's dropping I don't
even think I've made Rob for shirts to
be honest so I need to find out who
makes this shirt because it's super soft
super comfortable could you look at
Grant Morrison's JLA I don't know I mean
that seems like it'd be too far back and
I've never done what never really did
new for you to Justice League proper so
all the mid we'll start with JLA and
then work our way forward the only
problem with that is JLA and JSA
crossover when it comes to thy kingdom
come
so I'd have to do JSA at the same time
which could cause some confusion between
people who are reading it so I don't
know maybe it'll work maybe we can give
it a shot and see if it happens I have
no idea
let's see release punisher max is paid
paid content on bidding up I guess I
could I don't want to put my content
behind a paywall
so I don't really like that idea too
much Avengers vs. x-men he already did
that Majumdar's post house of him it's
really weird because he's like bonded
with a fury so it's like this uber
reality-warping you it's crazy
what do you what he's able to do let's
see do the multiverse have its own
living tribunal and one above all
there's only one living tribunal and one
above all throughout the entire
multiverse that's what you're asking
which DC and Marvel character would you
choose to be with for the rest of time
romantically why would you ask that but
it would definitely be Emma Frost
so I definitely heard so YouTube didn't
notify you of the stream yeah YouTube
has a really bad habit of just not doing
its job right so let's see a lot of you
Deadpool the duck I liked you at some
point
Emma is BAE yes she is what are your
thoughts on Doomsday Clock and the
future of the DC Universe and Watchmen
um I don't know I mean Doomsday Clock
doesn't fit into any kind of continuity
like I mean that's what Jeff John said
it's not like you have to read this
story that story then Doomsday Clock in
and this story comes after it it's just
it's removed it involves DC characters
but it looks like it centers more on the
Watchmen um I wouldn't be surprised if
it was a story that covered what
happened
you know what led to the watchman being
involved in the DC Universe I have no
idea I would think so but I don't I
don't know either way I'm excited for it
I mean having a watchman in the main DC
Universe invites a ton of different
possibilities and crossovers and stories
and so on so unlock the button I thought
the button was an amazing sandwich not
amazing sandwich amazing story what do I
think I was going to read that next
comment what do I think it was my
favorite sandwich my favorite sandwich
the button was an amazing sandwich my
favorite sandwich is probably like
peanut butter and jelly honestly I'll
just go the classic one so let's see
can you explain cosmic armor Superman I
have no idea what you're talking about
so yes sandwich a lot of people think
the way I say sandwich is funny I mean
uh no hoax your favorite pizza I imagine
that like an Incredible Hulk pizza it's
just
I'll have the incredible ho pizza what
comes on now everything we have like
interesting we got a crazy plus we die
the bread green you're hungry now let's
see do you think Hydra cap is going to
stay I have no idea if I wanted what I
they said he's going to stay but I
honestly don't know for certain so all
the meats see all the meats get put on
there let's see uh Wow Rodrick Rogers
jeez man if you go into audiobooks I
will definitely buy your books also with
the marvel legacy changed some of the
releases to buy weekly like DC rebirth
yes they already have the problem with
that is they haven't lower the price so
right now for a Marvel comic it's like
399 all right I'm pretty sure I get mine
on comiXology you don't even pay
attention anymore but it's basically
like four bucks all right
you have to pay that twice a month now
if you want their stories but they're
keeping the price the same and they're
not lowering them so now comics are
going to be even more expensive from you
know coming from Marvel Comics so it's
going to be kind of it's kind of silly
to be honest if you ask me that I don't
know I think it's gonna cause more harm
than good I think Marvel sales are going
to take even more and they're not going
to understand why it's like because your
prices are still the same that's why
well I kind of like I know what Marvel
thinks my comic book fans are not rich
all right they are not rich people
they're college kids or high school kids
sometimes your middle school kids like
they do not have all the money in the
world
so me and Benny we're never fighting uh
agreed that Pizza joke yeah I thought it
was hilarious so let's see what do I
mean I read my comics on comiXology so
um Rob rebirth uh let's see but did he
get you to read manga no not really I
couldn't get into manga I have not
played persona 5 so yeah one worthy Thor
is really good like I really love
unworthy Thor cable and Deadpool that
was a pretty enjoyable story yes it was
why can't Hollywood make Fantastic Four
work because they have a fundamental
misunderstanding of comic book movies
plus it's a corporate movie made by
corporate machines so it's never going
to be good one of my thoughts on Wonder
Woman I loved Wonder Woman we talked
about on the podcast yesterday so you
guys to go over there and check it out
but I love Wonder Woman I thought it
wasn't
I thought was a really really good story
in a really good movie so your dog
watches my videos one glad somebody does
that's cool that's pretty awesome
let's see
Wow so many questions rolling in so fast
it's almost hard to keep up now let's
see bring back rob plays I know I
thought about just like just kind of
killing time on minecraft or something
like that just doing like ASMR sessions
and just like helping people fall asleep
while I play minecraft I have no idea I
don't know
I mean minecraft is a really good game
to help people fall asleep to I mean
this is kind of fun so do I still play
destiny now I've got bored or destiny I
stopped playing that so Wow um VLA I'm
not really sure I pronounce your last
name I'm not going to try to I'm not
going to I'm not going to screw up your
last name I promise we're just going to
say feeling I think is how you pronounce
that let's see that's thanks for every
video here's a pizza for you my favorite
pizza well I appreciate that in my
favorite pizza is pepperoni definitely
so density to appear soon will you play
it nah probably not let's see uh wicked
where can you find about where can you
find out about upcoming DC events um
news aramas really good about that kind
of thing so let's see have you seen the
Thor infinity war teaser no what there's
no for infinity war teaser
what's the Thor infinity war teaser see
now I got a look enough
for infinity war teaser
is this thorne with his roommate again
it's a hold on let me watch living the
service he's playing with toys no Thor
Tori
he hasn't been cast
uh-huh
okay so it's just like more of it yes
it's more like a little featurette thing
as opposed to a whole okay cool so it's
not like a little trailer or anything
just kind of like a future at that works
um let's see that's that's it's not
here's yummy it's cool yeah yeah Gore in
the MCU would be really cool like that'd
be pretty awesome so um
Amanda Waller phantom ring that's movie
right there that'd be amazing to like
Amanda Waller where the Phantom ring
would be nuts so let's see what happened
to my pre only well different amazing
spider-man series it's still there it's
all my oh I may have taken it off the
front of the channel now that I think
about it which that might be kind of a
problem it's kind of an issue especially
with spider-man coming up now like that
should not be that way oh yeah I put
four up there Omega storm was popular at
the time well it still is but you know
amazing spider-man we should probably
put it up we should scroll up a new to
spider-man start here there we go okay
one of the new spider-man stuff is up
there so anyway
fear itself will probably end up being
later would you come out to New York
City have some fans out here who would
love to buy you a few drinks well I
appreciate that the alternative facts
I'll probably be there doing New York
comic-con the New York comic-con is a
one convention that we just never really
miss so none of the League of volunteers
nobody's won the rock for Ranger you
haven't missed out don't worry he hasn't
missed anything so let's see have I
played injustice - yeah I played a
little bit it's pretty fun it looks
great you know does DC have an unlimited
comic books similar to em oh no I don't
think there's a DC unlimited not that I
know of anyway so um Captain America
series probably not uh let's see Rob how
do we get Rob portrays just in an email
Rob's giveaway at gmail.com so do you
like Black Adam he's okay I mean he's
character that's interesting but I don't
know but just here to see if my
girlfriend's in the government I like it
when people like I'll see cut people
post comments like that every once in a
while you know it'll be like like
somebody wants to come it was it was
like won some popcorn
get your own but can you please cover
the first issue of irredeemable by Mark
Waid I don't really enjoyed any
redeemable to be honest like I never
really could get into it
the League of volunteers what a League
of volunteers
the League of volunteers comic
- series written by Rob Curley an
adventure team books at an island in the
1940s characters drawn from Irish
history mythology it's part of a planned
universe of Irish heroes and villains
now that's probably not going to happen
I'm probably not going to make a video
on that so you have a theory that Hydra
cap is is ultimate cap um that I would
agree with except that Hydra Capri
members like Civil War and all those
things and that never happened
civil wars we know what anyway never
happened in the Ultimate Universe - Thor
Garrick Masterson I have no idea and I
have no reason to ask where he went -
I'm doing the Helen Keller he's gone so
let's see what is Flash's best comics I
think flash rebirth is probably his best
comic so do I play cod zombies whatever
I can everyone so long so let's see
favorite comic artist writer a favorite
comic artist is Alex Ross favorite
writer is Jonathan Hickman so Rob
nuraghe I guess man I love the game
cable Maasai war Siri that was really
really fun so I love secret Empire
number three I love the way it ended
I like seeing all these changes with
these characters because I know they're
all going to go back to the status quo I
think a lot of the backlash that's
coming from people are the ones who just
don't realize that it's all going to go
back to the way it was before I mean
it's not it's not going to stay this way
forever it'll go back it'll change I
mean that's just the way goes so what
got me into comics I used to watch what
was it
explain the animated series when I was
younger and my dad got me a comic by
Batman and a sovereign seven sovereign
seven comic for those guys old enough to
remember that small short-lived series
by Claremont and I love the Batman
account I didn't really care about
sovereign 7 but love the Batman comic
and got an iconic sever since so let's
see
well Wolverine go back to the way he was
the old the dead Wolverine is probably
going to come back I mean
let's see where do I start with silver
surfer you don't know um you start with
it you start with Marvel now 1.0 and
then just kind of jump into that when
Dan Slott took over basically but be
aware if what you're looking for is like
the cosmic Silver Surfer then just start
with like start with any of his stories
that happen after annihilation and then
just read from there the problem with
that is that almost all of Silver Surfer
stuff during annihilation or from the
time annihilation started all the way up
until Dan Slott took over it's just
tie-ins to everything so you're just
going to have to like read you know all
kinds of stuff I don't like Dan slots
run I don't think it's very good at all
it's really boring to me it's literally
him and like this chick named Don Green
would just like traveling around the
universe it's there's no real fun cosmic
stuff at all it's kind of boring to me
so Jaime will probably come back I don't
know why you wouldn't but love your
voice no homo it's fine you don't have
to put that but I appreciate that
let's see old man Logan for life yeah oh
man Logan is pretty solid alright guys
we didn't want to wrap this episode up
on this is fine I just want to answer
some questions for you guys and talk to
you guys about the x-men and trying to
get my thoughts sorted out and figure
out what I want to do and sort of go
from there but anyway guys uh yeah I'm
gonna bounce off here and I will catch
you guys later please